- Hi everyone.
This is Jeremy Schifeling
from Khan Academy.
Thanks so much for taking time
to join me in this big week,
either before the start of school
or in the middle of the start of school
depending on where you're calling from.
Wherever you are in your
own educational journey
this school year,
I'm really excited that you joined us
for our student experience demo.
This all about a chance to
basically go behind the curtain
and see what your students
see on Khan Academy.
So you can make the most
of this tool this year.
That being said just a couple
of things to get started here.
I wanna call out as always
that like every Khan Academy webinar,
we will be recording the session
and then sharing it in your
email in about an hour.
So that'll happen automatically
whether you can join it for
the whole session or
whether you have to run out
and make dinner or anything else.
So have no fear you will have
that in your inbox shortly.
In the meantime,
you can even get the slides themselves
through the handout section right now
on the Go To Webinar control panel.
So if you're really eager like
me to see where we're headed,
feel free to grab that PDF
under the handout section.
And then finally, because
just like last week session,
I wanna make this as
interactive as possible.
Please, please, please make sure
that you're logged into
your Khan Academy account.
That way you can follow
along and actually experience
everything just the same
way that your students do.
And I'll make it a really fun session
and a really powerful one as well.
That being said,
I wanna sort of cut to the chase here
and talk about one of our big philosophies
here at Khan Academy.
Which is that great teaching
involves great empathy.
I love this quote from Anne Lieberman.
Which is that great teachers,
don't just teach kids and lecture kids.
They empathize with kids.
They respect them.
They understand where they're coming from
and they serve those needs
through that empathy.
And I think to put it in a more sort of
a practical standpoint or
a practical perspective,
what I've heard from a lot of educators
as I never really got
to Khan Academy until
I tried using it as a student.
Either for my own courses in college
where my own teacher test prep.
We're just trying to understand
what my students were saying.
That was the light bulb moment.
That's when I got it.
And so please put yourself
into your students' shoes
for the next 25 minutes or so,
and sort of experience what
your students experience.
So that way you can give them
the best possible experience this Fall.
Okay, to get things started,
we're gonna begin with you joining
my classroom on Khan Academy,
the same way that students might set up
for your own classroom.
So again, if you're already
logged into Khan Academy,
all you wanna do is go
to bit.ly/khaninvite
So I'm gonna actually show you
what that looks like over here.
So check this out.
So here I have, you know,
my teacher accounts set up.
And what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna come over here
to bit.ly/khaninvite.
I'm also gonna put that in
the chat just so you can click
the link for even easier access.
And once you're over there,
what you will see is a
slow the invitation popup.
And it's gonna say, hey,
you're joining the
student experience demo.
Are you ready to sort of
plug into this classroom?
And I know it might seem a little strange,
like what is this classroom
that Jeremy has set up.
But just is roll with
me a little bit here.
Go ahead and click Join
Student Experience Demo.
And you will now be a registered
member of our sample class.
And I will give you two minutes
to do the same on your side.
I wish, I wish, I wish, I could play
some jeopardy music right now,
but at the very least just
follow the invites on the screen,
bit.ly/khaninvite, join my class.
And if you have any questions whatsoever,
feel free to ask them
using the question section
of the Go To Webinar control panel.
I'm happy to answer
those live and over texts
as we go along.
So again, join my class
and that'll be the first
step towards seeing
what your students see.
Looks like no questions coming
in yet, which is awesome.
I'm definitely, probably
not gonna be identical
to the experience your students have.
Mine always ask questions
about everything,
but hopefully that means everyone
is making good progress
and joining my class.
And what you'll be able
to see as a teacher,
whether you're doing this over Zoom
or doing this in person
is you'll be able to see students coming
into your class in real time.
So check this out.
I'm gonna come over to my roster.
This is the student experience demo.
I'm gonna click refresh.
And what you're gonna see now
is that all the teachers
across the country
who were involved in this webinar,
they have just joined this class,
which is pretty incredible.
So sure enough, they're coming in.
Ally's here.
Alyssa's here.
Christine's here.
Diane's here.
Thank you all so much.
And what I'm gonna do
is actually include you
in an assignment shortly,
but I will get back to that in a moment.
I wanna answer a couple questions
cause' folks are asking,
Balayla says it looks like I'm
still my teacher's account.
Absolutely.
Would you might've noticed
that my demo window here
is that after you joined my
class kind of always kicks
you back to your teacher home page.
And that kind of keeps you centered
on the teacher experience,
but have no fear.
I'm gonna show you where
to actually confirm
that you are now a member
of my class as a learner.
Great question Balayla.
Diane had the same question.
You get the point, Lisa had the same.
So sorry, I didn't call
that out, my apologies,
but yeah, you will come back
to your teacher dashboard,
but have no fear.
You are now registered in my class
and it's showing up on
the screen right here.
So, I think at this point
everyone's had a chance to join.
We have about 30 students
from across the country,
which is awesome.
So thank you all for joining.
What I wanna do now is do
a couple things for you.
So first of all,
just sort of gave you a sense of
how you might do this on your own side.
I'm gonna make my screen a little larger.
So it's easier to see.
And if you ever wanna
share your own class code
with your students,
all you have to do is come into
your classroom at Khan Academy,
come over to the Students tab
right down here under admin.
And then there's this
nice share class code link
right in the upper right hand corner.
By clicking here, I can grab the code.
Just like the one I gave you.
Now I put it behind a fancy
little bookmark from bi.tly
but you can share this link
on whatever form you want
with your students and they can join
the exact same way you did.
You could even print these instructions
if you wanna share them in a different way
or different languages.
But this is the easiest way
to get your students started.
So there's your class code?
There's your link.
Then like I said,
you can see your students
coming in in real time,
which is awesome.
And now that you had your
students here and you're saying,
okay, this all looks really good.
Ally's here.
Elleen's here.
Diane's here.
Let me actually get you off to
the races with an assignment.
So I'm gonna come over
to the assign section.
What I'm gonna do is just walk you through
what the teacher is saying.
Now that her students or
his students are enrolled.
As I come down here, I say, you know what?
I'm gonna start you off.
Maybe in this case, you know what?
I'm gonna switch things up.
I'm gonna start you off
with the grammar lesson
because I got some feedback
at my last webinar.
Jeremy, I love all this
stuff you're doing,
but it's too much math, math, math.
Let's shake it up a little bit.
You're absolutely right.
So let's do a grammar lesson right now.
Let's focus on identifying nouns.
So I come over to assign.
I click the little check box.
I click assign one.
I'm gonna say all of
my students in my class
are gonna get this assignment.
So here we go.
All students you have till tomorrow,
what we're gonna do it right now.
I'm gonna have you all
do the same question set
so we can review together as a class,
which is pretty powerful
over video conference.
And I'm gonna assign that right now.
And so if we switch back
into our student experience,
you've gone from enrolling in my class
to now having a chance to
actually get information
and assignments as a student.
Now to get there,
what I want you to do is a
switch from your teacher view,
kind of like the teacher
hat that you're wearing
into student mode and
see your student view.
And the way you're gonna do that.
And I'll walk you through
it right here on my screen,
is you're gonna come over here.
You're going to come up to your name
in the upper right hand corner.
I'm gonna actually shrink it a little bit
so you can see that.
So I have Salvador.
You might be Diane,
you might be Elleen, whatever it is.
You're gonna click right in
the upper right hand corner.
And then you're gonna click learner home.
And basically what this is
telling Khan Academy is,
hey I'm about to switch identities.
I'm a teacher and a learner.
And in this case, I wanna
focus on the learner view.
So learner home is where you wanna go
and if you've actually done it,
what you should now see is under
the student experience demo,
you will see this assignment
that I've just given,
which is identifying nouns.
And just to sort of reiterate
as I have here in this teacher note,
if you click your name one more time,
you'll notice that there
are these notifications
that are letting you know that
you've just received this assignment.
So if you click the notification link,
you can see that assignment has come in.
This is one that you can
communicate with students.
Obviously you can let them
know about assignments verbally
during a Zoom session via
Vermont, via ClasDojo,
via Google Classroom, all
sorts of different ways.
But fundamentally every
time you make an assignment,
it'll pop up in the notification section.
And so now to move on to the last section,
I wanna give you a chance to
get into your student view.
So if you haven't done this already,
take one minute right
now and click your name
and then click into learner home.
And your time starts now.
I've always wanted to say that.
Always wanted to be a game show host.
Come on into your student view.
Again, you're coming over to your name
and you're clicking learner home
and they'll take you right there.
Just to make sure
everyone's on the same page
before we move forward, I'm
gonna answer some questions.
Regina did get a little prompt that said
I was not able to get into the session.
It asked me to create an account
or log into my existing account.
And that's totally fine.
If you don't want to use your
existing teacher account,
you can always create
a new student account
maybe with your personal
Gmail, for instance,
for the purposes of this session.
Totally fine to keep it separate.
Great question, Regina.
Okay, about 15 seconds left.
Just wanna make sure that everyone
is now in the learner home,
where you're gonna see your assignments.
You're gonna see all the interaction
with the teacher in this case.
And once the timer is up, we'll
move on to the next section.
Thank you all for being rockstar students.
I can tell this class is gonna go far.
Okay, time's up.
Let's move on to the third step.
And that is chance to
actually do the assignment.
And I know this might seem a little funny
to actually be doing
the work on Khan Academy
as opposed to assign the work.
But again, I think it's so important
to really see that fundamental thing
that your students experience.
What does an assignment look like?
How does it feel?
How do I get help when I'm stuck?
And so what I would love
for you to do is do exactly
I'm gonna show you on my screen right now.
Which is like come over here
to my assignment section.
I say, aha, my teacher
has made this assignment, identify nouns.
I scroll over, I click the start button.
And I'm literally just
gonna go through this
and try to answer these to
the best of my abilities.
So noun, not a noun, not a noun, noun.
Check, get that nice little reward, right?
The next question and what
I'll challenge you to do
as you go through this
is to actually try getting
it wrong once in a while.
We're asking for a hint just to see
what that experience looks like.
You know, especially
with all these students
learning over distance right now.
They may not always be able
to reach you with questions.
So in that case, how
can you instruct them on
how to use the hint system
and the video system?
Well, first of all, try it out yourself
and then you'll be empowered
to really support them going forward.
So spend about five minutes
going through it right now.
I'll start the timer.
And again, just to sort
of retrace my steps,
I'm in my learner home, I'm
going to my assignment section,
I'm clicking start.
And I'm just literally going
through this as a student would
one question after another,
getting stuck some times getting hints
and getting a sense of how this all feels
and how it all works.
Cause' once you understand that
you can really translate
it for your students.
So as you do that, again feel free
to ask any questions via
the questions feature
and go to webinar.
I'll be happy to answer those live.
Balayla says, should we
watch the video also?
Totally up to you, Balayla.
If you're one of those superstar students
who zooming ahead and you have time
and not only do the exercise
or watch the video, go for it.
Get a sense of what those
con videos feel like.
Great question.
Christine is saying I can
get to the learner home,
but I can't see the assignment.
So I just wanna call this out.
You may have multiple courses here
depending on how many
things you've signed up
for as a learner.
Definitely make sure that you come over
to the student experience demo,
which has the name of
my particular course.
Good question, Christine.
And Melissa says, will
this link still be active
so we can show the kids
the student view demo.
Absolutely.
I'm gonna leave this classroom up
for the entire academic year.
So if you ever wanna log back in
and sort of reconnect with this experience
or share with your own
students, by all means.
And also know that you
can certainly do the same
on your own end.
You can always create a sample classroom.
You can add yourself to it
and really see what students are seeing.
We're making it easy for
your students to play around
in a kind of a sandbox
environment if you will.
So definitely feel free to take advantage
of all these resources
both now and in the future.
Thanks for asking that, Melissa.
Okay, we're about halfway through.
Hopefully you're having fun.
I'm getting in touch
with those old school grammar mechanics.
I know it's probably been awhile unless
you do teach grammar yourself.
But definitely fun to
see what our students see
and see the structure that's built in
as far as those rewards, when
students are getting it right.
And also the support structure
that's in place when they
need a little extra help.
So Sherry says my school is not listed.
And what she's referring
to is a school picker
that appears at the very top
of the Khan Academy dashboard.
Let me show you what that looks like.
So here I am logged in
as a teacher, again.
It says, add your school
and you may search
in your zip code and you
may not find your school.
Absolutely no worries.
You can still use it a 100%.
We are working really hard
to get additional schools add to this.
So if you see any trouble with it, Sherry,
please send us a request
after this webinar.
And we'll try to get that school added.
I'm gonna show you how
to make that request
in about 10 minutes.
So thanks for calling that out.
Let's see here.
Sherry is asking if I am tutoring,
should this process work?
Absolutely.
Whether you're working with
five students or 150 students,
everything I'm showing
you is exactly the same.
And so whether it's choosing content
for your students or your
tutees, making assignments,
everything can be done no matter
how many students you have.
Thanks for asking, Sherry.
Let's see here, Tamera is saying,
is there a way to have my student access
the practice questions that I located
by doing a search on the
topic, ideals of democracy?
I haven't seen a way to find
them from the student page.
Yeah, so such a good question.
One of those sort of powerful,
hidden things in Khan Academy
is that you can come in here
and you can search for whatever you want.
So ideals of democracy, well off
here's the awesome
thing that Tamera found.
You can definitely, you know,
go into your teacher classroom
and add that as a class
that you wanna that use
and go through the full signup process
like I demoed in about five minutes ago.
But what you can actually
do is from this page,
you can start to assign it.
So check this out.
Here's this assign bar at the very top.
And if we make this a little bit bigger,
she can blow this up on your screen.
I can say, aha, ideal of democracy.
This is the perfect piece of practice.
I'm gonna assign it to my
class, to these students.
I can give them the same
questions or different questions.
I can give them a clear deadline
and that way, without even
going into the assignment mode,
you can assign something
the minute you find it.
So a really powerful way to
immediately get that practice
into your students' hands.
Hopefully that's helpful.
Good question Tamera.
All right, bout 10 seconds left.
Lisa is asking what
would be a valuable way
to use Khan Academy for virtual learning.
Lisa, I would highly recommend
that you check out last week's webinar,
which is on our YouTube playlist.
And I'll share a link later.
Which gets into all this
stuff around, you know,
using Khan Academy during a Zoom session
before Zoom session, after a Zoom session.
But then the bottom line is
you don't wanna have too much lecture
in that rare moment of
teacher student interaction.
Instead you wanna make it really engaging.
Like Sal Khan talked about
there's a New York Times update
a couple of weeks ago.
And so try to use Khan Academy to offload
some of that stuff.
Have the students watch
the video ahead of time.
Have them do some practice ahead of time.
And that way you can use
those virtual sessions
for lots of engagement,
where you make cold calls,
you ask questions, you give pop quizzes
and get students thinking in real time.
That's my advice.
Okay.
Let me pause on the
questions for a second.
And I'll come back to this I promise.
And the interest of time I
wanna now actually switch
from student mode and the teacher mode.
So you can see the fruits of your labor.
So everyone's done the
assignment and by the way,
here's one really cool thing that's unique
to the Fall at Khan Academy.
As you probably heard,
we have this cool program
called learn storm.
Which is like everything on Khan Academy,
a free program to motivate your students
to really be their best,
especially at this very tough moment.
And to help celebrate as a
class, your progress together,
you can always come to
your learn storm tracker.
So check this out.
So you're learn storm tracker
is always gonna be found at the top
of your Khan Academy dashboard.
So here I am, as a teacher, I'm logged in.
And sure enough, the very first
thing is check my progress.
How am I doing on learn storm,
You could literally show
this to your students
to get them so pumped up.
So you come over here to
student experience demo
to the name of our class.
I checked for progress and check this out.
Watch this climb so fast as a tribute
to all the hard work you just did.
So if you ever need a little extra way
to bring mood and excitement
for the back to school season,
this is the way to say, hey,
we're all in this thing together.
And even though we may
be a part of this moment,
we are working together to do big things.
And you can track the progress
with this learn storm
tool and share that with
your class during a zoom session,
just by sharing your screen.
So definitely check that
out, it's pretty fun.
Okay.
Now back to the flow.
So you've done this
assignment as a student.
What would you do with that
information as a teacher?
Let's review this together.
So I'm gonna come back to my class
and again, it's called
student experience demo.
And this time, instead of going to assign,
I'm gonna go to scores.
I'm actually make this
a little bit bigger.
So it's a little easier to see.
And so I'm gonna refresh this.
I'm gonna check out the results
from all of your hard
work on this assignment.
I'm so sorry to put
everyone on the spot here,
but I do wanna showcase some
of the great stuff you all have done.
To go over to identifying nouns,
which is the exercise you just did.
And while I check this out,
I love this so much because
it's kind of like x-ray
vision for teachers
where you can drill down
to the question level
and figure out how things are going.
And so one of the things
that I immediately see
is a question one, you all are nailing.
26 out of 29 of you got
that on the very first try?
Fantastic.
Whereas question four was
maybe more of a struggle.
So I wanna drill down to
that question and say, aha,
I see that six students
got the incorrect answer.
So maybe I reteach this one.
And I go over things like,
is a preposition a noun
is something like exciting
adjective, like creepy a noun.
And I use it as a teaching moment to say,
I know a lot of us are sort
of running into trouble here,
but let's solve it together.
Let's come together as a class
to address those misconceptions
and make sure that we're all on
the same page moving forward.
And again, you can
definitely on your own time,
click in and see the exact students
who are correct or incorrect.
But for now it kind
keeps it all anonymous,
which is nice for you because
you can show your students
that you're paying
attention to their work.
And they are looking at
it as a class together
without calling out any one student.
It's just a nice way to
bring the class together
around your shared work
and your shared experience.
So I highly recommend going
into these assignment scores
to give that kind of
report out to your class.
Okay.
We're now back to our flow now.
What we've talked about so far
is getting started as a student,
going into your learner home,
doing your first assignment.
But if you followed any of
the things that Sal Khan
has been talking about
these last couple of years,
even pre COVID, you know, that assignments
are just the tip of the iceberg.
One of the things that we strongly believe
in at Khan Academy is the
power of course mastery
to really help students do their best
especially in this difficult moment.
And that's the idea rather
than just move together.
Lock step and say, hey, you know,
half our class is maybe
not getting it right,
but that's okay.
We've got to move forward.
Let's have each student
continue to work on that skill
until they reach mastery.
So when they move on to the
next skill and the next unit,
they don't have those Swiss cheese gaps
in their foundations.
And they move forward stronger
and more confident than ever before.
So if you want to take
advantage of course mastery,
check this out.
I'm gonna come back into
my picture dashboard
just to show you what this looks like.
I come into the course
mastery section over here.
So not assignments.
I click placement.
I'm gonna set a goal.
So check this out.
I'm gonna say, I wanna create a goal
for the 40 new students in my class.
And I'm gonna say, instead
of focusing on grammar,
let's move to second grade math.
And I want you to master
this topic by let's say
the end of the school year.
So June 1st give or take.
So we create that goal.
And now what's gonna happen on your end
is back in your learner home.
You're gonna start to see that filter in
to your course mastery section.
So to show you what that looks like,
we're gonna switch back
into our learner view.
So as you may recall,
we click our name in the
upper right hand corner.
We click learner home
and this time wallah,
a new section that's appeared.
Before we had assignments.
And we did the assignment.
That was great.
But now there's course mastery.
And a dig into course mastery.
Here's exactly what you do.
You can follow along on your own screen.
So first of all, you click second grade.
That's the goal for the year.
I want you to master this body of content,
all the related skills.
I click into that.
Now, if you are perhaps
a third grade teacher
and you wanna make sure
that your students master
in second grade before moving on,
you can have them to start
with a course challenge.
That's a quick way to recap
how they're doing at the start.
But for our purposes,
let's say, no, thanks.
And let's just follow the blue buttons.
Cause' really that's kind of
the digital cookie crumb trail
that you want to teach your
students to always follow.
When in doubt, look for the blue.
So in this case, we go to get
started under the first unit.
Then we go for the first blue button,
which is the first skill
of second grade math
adding within 20 visually.
And again, we click the Start button
and did we dive right into
this practice session?
Let's go.
So just like before,
I would love for you
to spend a few minutes
doing your first experience of
course mastery as a student.
So you can see what that feels like.
So I'm gonna start the timer over here.
And again, just to retrace my steps.
I was back here at my teacher dashboard
and I came to my name.
I came to learner home.
And then I found out that
I had not just assignments,
but also course mastery.
I'm gonna refresh that while
there's course mastery.
I click second grade to dig
into this lofty goal we have.
Say, no thanks to course
challenge for now.
And then I just follow the blue buttons.
Get started and start this skill.
Now I'm off to the races.
So again, spend a few minutes
just going through that,
try getting a couple of answers, right?
A couple of wrong.
See how Khan Academy responds
and how it supports you along the way.
And as you do that,
I'm gonna answer some
questions that have come in.
So, let's see here.
Diane says,
do you have a suggestion for
how to pick just one assignment
for a particular topic?
When I assigned a topic to a student,
I assign to large number of assignments
and it became totally unmanageable,
which overwhelmed the student.
And I feel your pain, Diane,
because this is one of
the biggest pitfalls
that I encountered when I first
started using Khan Academy
is I would be over here
on my teacher screen.
And I would say, you know what,
I'm gonna do an assignment
and I'm gonna assign
basically an entire unit.
Well, the problem with that
is that I'm assigning 24 things at once.
That's video is maybe articles,
some practice that's way too much.
I highly recommend the
laser focus especially
at the start of the year.
You're just getting
your students warmed up
and you say there's only one
thing I want you to focus on.
And most likely that's the thing
that you've just talked about in class
during your last session.
So if I had just taught
about adding and subtracting within 20,
I would choose only that singular skill.
and I would assign only that.
And that way we have baby
steps in the Khan Academy,
as opposed to that feeling
of being overwhelmed.
Great question Diane.
Okay, Julian is saying,
how do you assign something
on Google Classroom?
So, the first thing is
you do have to assign it
using the techniques
we've already talked about
on Khan Academy if you
want to put a track it
on Khan Academy and get
all those valuable reports.
So that means either assigning it
through your teacher dashboard.
We're actually on the section itself.
You're using that little
assigned blue bar,
but that being said, once
you have something going,
here's what you can do next.
Let me actually just get
this going for you here.
Hold on one moment.
So we expand this.
You may get out of this modal mode.
You'll notice there's
this Google Classroom link
under every video and every practice.
And by clicking that link?
Just like you would a Facebook
link or a Twitter link.
You're basically sending it
to your Google Classroom.
So as long as you're logged into Google,
as long as your classroom is set up,
you can specifically send
that piece of content
straight into your classroom account.
And that's a nice supplement
to the assignments that
already exist in Khan Academy.
Hope that helps, okay.
Let's keep tabs on our timer here.
We're down to about two minutes.
Okay, great question Juliet.
Is a Tamera is doing well.
Lisa's doing well.
Let's see here.
Ooh, Ms. Delly says,
how do we archive last year's class
in order to start a new class this year?
Great question.
So if you have something
that you wanna get rid of,
cause' it's cluttering
up your kit or dashboard,
you can always come down to
the settings and just say,
you know what?
I'm gonna delete this class.
And the data still exists.
So the the students aren't
gonna lose their data.
But it we will be removed
from your dashboard.
So you don't have all this
information overwhelming you
cause' overwhelm is real,
not just for students,
but also for educators.
So definitely check that out. (mumbles)
All right, let's see here.
And Lisa said,
how do you get to that grade book again?
So if you ever wanna get back
to that assignment grade book,
all you do is assignments
and then scores and wallah.
You now have the results
for each of those sections.
So identify nouns.
Let's see how students did.
Okay.
So now we're down to the final 30 seconds.
Rosemary is saying,
do students do work with
pen and paper at desk?
Or can they sell digitally?
Ooh, such a good question.
I'm glad you brought that up Rosemary.
So when you were doing
work on Khan Academy,
you may have noticed this
and I hope this is one of the benefits
of actually doing these things
is that you can actually start to draw
on the screen as a student.
So whether you're using your computer
or Chromebook or tablet or phone,
you click this little button
and you can literally do some doodles
and some sort of quick
calculations right on your screen.
But, what I always
encourage students to do
is whatever is most effective for them.
If that means using pen and paper,
if that means using a little
sort of personal whiteboard
on their desk, by all means.
Great question.
All right.
So we have come to the end of step five
and now it's the big moment of truth.
So don't fail me now is our final step.
We're reviewing the progress together.
And I'm super excited to show you
not just course master
progress at a high level,
but specifically x-ray
view into the skills
that your students are generating.
So again, everyone in my class
has just completed their
first course mastery practice
which is awesome.
When I come here,
I can look at that through
two different lenses.
First of all, I have this lens
of overall course progress.
And I can say Melissa
and Pamela and Regina
are off to the races.
They're doing great.
And I can literally track
that at the unit level
and at the overall course level as well.
Cause all your goal is
always a 100% course mastery.
I want everyone in my class
to master all these skills.
However, just this summer,
have we rolled out a brand
new report called skills.
And here's where you find it.
So again, you're in
your teacher dashboard,
you're in your specific classroom
and you go to activity overview
and then you go to skills.
And what you will find here
are all the skills in your entire course.
Whether it's grammar, whether it's math,
whether it's science,
all laid out for you.
And then when you click on it,
you can actually see how everyone is doing
in terms of that spectrum
from first getting started,
getting familiar, getting proficient
and ultimately mastering that skill.
I think this is such a powerful thing
because you know, when I was a teacher,
I almost did all of my
assessment at the unit level.
And I knew who was exceeding in general
and who was struggling in general.
But I didn't always know
the specific students
and the specific skills
that were holding them back.
And now you have that
all on a single report.
So what you might say is, okay,
I'm feeling great about
Larry and Ori, Ms. Daniel,
but I'm a little worried
about Tami and Kristin.
And what you can do is you
can actually assign the skill
just to the students who might
be struggling a little bit.
And that way they get that extra practice
before you move on as a class.
So again, put them as extra goggles,
get a sense of how your class is doing.
And this is a really powerful new report
that I hope to help you try out.
Okay.
So now I know we're almost at time.
So I do wanna finish with
a quick recap for you.
If there are three things
that you wanna show your students
at the start of this year,
whether your school
year has already begun,
or whether it's about to begin next week
is number one, when in
doubt with registration,
the simplest thing to do is
just share your class link.
You come into your class.
You come to students and
you share that class code.
And that'll get students up
and running pretty quickly.
Number two, you're gonna
train your students
that once they've gone
ahead and registered,
all the action is gonna
appear on their learner home.
So they're gonna come up to their names.
They're gonna click learn her home.
And they're gonna see all classes
they're a part of and
all their assignments
and all their course mastery on one place.
And then finally as mentioned here in the
third point assignments
and course mastery,
they'll be notified right
here on their learner home.
So here are the notifications,
here's, what's coming in.
Here's what to do.
And that way,
even if everyone is learning
at home learning remotely,
you can centralize that
the single source of truth
about what you're handing
out all in one place.
That being said a couple of things
I wanna call out before
I start taking your questions live again.
I know that they're gonna
be more questions either now
or in the next few weeks.
So I want you to have all
the resources possible.
Number one, I wanna try
to take as many questions
as possible right now.
But if you don't get
your question answered
or something else comes
up over the long weekend
or in the showers of getting ready
for the first day of school,
here are two amazing resources.
Number one, you can always ask
our support team using this
link bit.ly/khanquestion
Basically what that is doing is
it's taking you from the
help link at the very top.
So click your name, you click help,
and then you report a problem.
And even though that
sounds kind of negative,
it's basically a chance to say, hey,
I've got an idea for Khan Academy
or I have a bug and Khan Academy,
or I have a question about Khan Academy.
And we typically respond
in a couple of hours
even at the start of the school year.
So definitely lean on our
community support team for help.
And then in addition,
make sure to check out
with fellow teachers
what they're doing and learn
from their best practices.
And you can do that on our Facebook group
called Teach with Khan.
And as you can see,
people are saying help,
I have a question.
And teachers are sort of coming in
and sort of sharing their
expertise left right in central.
So take advantage of that
tool as the school year dawns.
Okay, that being said, let me
take your questions live now.
So Stephanie, I'm gonna lead off of you.
You say our students have
fake Google email addresses
Khan Academy recognizes them,
but it's gonna work in
the same way to login.
Absolutely.
Even if you've totally made
up these Google accounts,
just for the purpose of
getting your students enrolled,
everything is the same.
They come in, they log in
with those fake credentials
that you created for them.
And they're gonna see
that same learner home,
those same assignments, that
same course mastery goals,
regardless of how they log in.
So, definitely you're gonna
see very similar results.
Let's see here.
Melissa says is the drawing
tool available for English?
Yeah, great question.
Let's let you try that out together.
So we're gonna come back to Khan Academy.
We're gonna come back to
our student experience demo,
and we're gonna go back into
that sort of grade book,
if you will, identifying nouns.
And what I'm happy to say is that wallah,
here's the virtual
whiteboard, even for grammar.
So if you want to do
any incentives diagrams,
if you want to break out
your digital red pen,
by all means go ahead and take
a take advantage of this tool
cause' it is a nice way.
Even if you don't have a
whiteboard built in like Zoom has,
you're using a different platform,
you can absolutely
start drawing right here
and get your students off to the races.
Great question, Melissa.
Ally says, how can I unassign something?
Oh I assigned too much not
knowing what I was doing.
And I totally get it Ally.
I was in that same boat when
I was playing around with
Khan Academy at first.
But what you wanna do
is you wanna come back
here to the assignments section.
You wanna say, manage this time.
So that's the last of these three options.
And then you wanna come in
here and say, you know what?
I went a little bit overboard.
Let me go ahead and edit this assignment
and this case, you know, maybe
I'll go ahead and delete it.
And in that case,
you don't have to have all
these students suffering under
all these assignments.
You can keep it way more simple.
Hope that helps.
Okay, great question.
Let's see.
Stephanie says I'm an
instructional math coach
with no kids of my own to
experiment on thanks Jeremy.
Okay.
Absolutely, I have to tell you all,
in addition to being a former teacher,
I have two little kids at home
and they are my Khan Academy, Guinea pigs.
So they are so sick of all this stuff,
but I have tried it out all on them.
Definitely get tested,
if not get approved.
Okay.
Rosemary says, can I assign mastery
in small chunks with a short deadline?
For example, I wanna see how a
new fourth grader understands
third grade place value.
Yeah, so I actually have
a really cool new
resource for you Rosemary.
Right now is sort of a mid
flaw of course mastery,
which is an operates at this course level,
which can often feel too massive
especially at the start of the year.
But brand new on Khan Academy this year
is the ability to come in click courses
and then seeing the things
called get ready courses.
And what that is, is our attempt to get
your students up to speed for grade level,
given that so much there's up
in the air this past spring.
And so you're gonna find
very curated sort of cuts
of just the most important
skills for third grade
or for algebra, for precalculus.
And so you can assign course
mastery for these courses,
and that can be done in a couple of weeks.
Not in 26 weeks.
And hopefully that'll get you
moving a little bit faster.
Hope that helps Rosemary, right?
Stephanie says, wahoo wahoo indeed.
Diane says I was excited to be joining.
Thank you for being here, Diane.
Thank you for being
such an awesome student.
Tamera says, can you
please explain a bit about
level up or down?
Ooh, such a good question.
I'm taking a government class
and I went through a practice set today.
I scored maybe like three out of four
or four to five or something.
It was the first time I had taken it.
And then I was surprised
to see the red down arrow.
What's going on?
Well, it's so funny.
You mentioned this Tamera cause' cell com
was actually on this
radio show this morning
I was listening to and
a parent called them
with the same exact
question, which is like,
how demoralizing is it for my kid?
If all of a sudden I see
the scores going down.
Well, the reason that that happens
is that what Khan is trying to do
is trying to always assess
the mastery level of your students.
And I want it to be pretty
clear right about this.
It doesn't want to say, hey, you know,
you mastered something in the past,
or you when you gave you
some space repetition
when we showed it to you again,
and this time you totally didn't get it,
well we can't really still call you
at sort of that master level.
And so when in doubt,
I highly recommend coming
back to your skills report.
So here's activity
overview, here's skills.
And check this out for every single level,
we will give you the
definition of what attempted,
familiar, proficient and master means.
So if you're ever wondering,
why did I go from master to proficient
or familiar to proficient person?
We will give you that intel
and that definition right here.
So hopefully be the Rosetta stone
if you will to explain
some of those conundrums.
Great question Tamera.
All right, let's see here.
Well, Diane says,
how has get ready for
fourth grade different
than using learn storm?
I'm so glad you asked,
because learn storm is more a
sort of key motivational thing
that runs across all the courses we offer.
So you may notice at
the top of Khan Academy,
in this course directory,
we kind of have this is a massive spectrum
of content offerings.
Everything from math, the
stem to arts and humanity,
even career courses.
And so what we say is,
no matter what you teach,
we wanna make sure that you get credit
for getting your students going
and your students get
motivation, especially
in this tough moment.
And so anytime you make an assignment
and your students make progress,
you will start to see that
learn storm tracker grow.
And that's true for get ready courses.
It's true for AP, art history
is true for everything.
That said, these get ready courses
were built specifically this year
given the fact that so many teachers said,
I'm a little bit worried about the Fall.
You know, my own class in the spring
didn't end the way it would normally.
We didn't cover all the content
we would normally get to.
So I can expect that some
of my students coming in
maybe a little bit less prepared
or a little bit less unready
than they would have been
in a normal year.
And so this is specifically
about plugging those holes,
catching them up on those key skills
so that in the middle of the year,
you don't learn for the Swiss cheese gaps
that might be holding your student back.
And again, if you assign
some of this work,
it will also count
towards the learn storm,
but it is a little more focused
on content than motivation.
Cause' learn storm is about motivation
at the end of the day.
Great question, Diane.
Okay.
So let me sort of
come back here and give you a quick recap.
I love that you all totally
rock my class today.
It makes me feel really good as a teacher
to see that so many folks
were getting proficient and
mastery on all those key skills.
What's more important
to me quite honestly,
is that you are ready to rock
your own classrooms this Fall.
If there's anything we can do
to support you along the way,
please let us know, ask
questions to our support team,
connect with us online,
or even let me know in the
survey after the session
what you wanna see next.
I have a team of a bunch of
ambassadors around the country
who are just chomping at the
bit to share their expertise
with you in response to your needs.
So if you let me know that you need
a webinar about motivation,
or you need a tool focused on XYZ content,
we will get to work on that.
In the meantime, I wish
you all an amazing,
and well-deserved long
weekend this weekend,
and then a great start or
resumption of the year next week.
I know there's a lot
resting on your shoulders,
but I also know you're gonna
knock it out of the park.
Thank you so much for all that you do,
and here's wishing you tremendous success.
Cheers everyone.